I suppose i'll leave my brother back oh yeah right
i have been falling for 30 minutes
surprise i am loki of asgard and i am burdened with glorious purpose i am agod you dull creature and i will not be bullied by
puny god
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality I want you to help us fix it
i need your unique Loki
perspective
brother, heimdall
you'd better be ready
glorious
I suppose loki picking up the tesseract
in m game might have caused some concern
it is very exciting the world of the tva is an is
a bureaucratic is a world of bureaucratic order
and of course loki is the god of mischief and
chaos so you have the forces of order and chaos
coming together and that's where our story
starts
Welcome back everyone this is going
to be my new marvel loki trailer video in thor
video explaining how the loki series connects
to thor love and thunder and what's happening
with thor during the events of the loki series
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos i will be
doing videos for all the episodes it's going to
start next week you don't have to wait that long
we're doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want them to do with loki
in the marvel movies after the loki series we
will be getting a loki season 2 eventually
so he will be going back and forth between
the loki episodes in the future marvel movies like
they're never going to completely get rid of loki
but marvel released a bunch more footage recently
of him with chris hemsworth and thor in all the
movies tom hiddleston has been talking about
the thor movies in the future of his character
so obviously the loki series is a time travel
series he'll be jumping all over the timeline
past present and future and also through
the multiverse and alternate realities
so just to explain the marvel timeline during
the events of the loki series it works like this
the opening scenes of loki episode 1 you've
actually seen in the trailers is basically
starting right after this moment avengers end game
when this version of loki steals the tesseract
in the year 2012. it's meant to be right at
the end of the first avengers movie then as
he's portaling away with the tesseract he winds up
in the gobi desert here somewhere near mongolia it
looks like just based on these people that's
why they have been wearing that same costume
it's a very iron man one inspired scene of him
waking up in the sand like what just happened
here like after iron man in the mark one lands in
the sand and just sits up like what just happened
a lot of the loki series will be parodying moments
from earlier marvel movies so it'll be really fun
to spot those easter eggs but that's when this
character who's called hunter b15 comes to arrest
him and book him in the time variance authorities
time prison you see her hauling him in he's all
pissed off because she kicks his ass and he has no
idea what's going on at this point this place they
take him the timekeeper citadel the official name
is the citadel at the end of time but i think it's
just easier to refer to it as the time keeper
citadel it exists in its own pocket dimension
outside of normal space time protected from any
potential changes in the normal mcu timeline
which as they said they monitor in police to keep
the past present and future unfolding according
to the timekeeper's plans i've already talked
about how sinister that sounds we'll be talking
about that during the loki episodes like who is
the real villain here the time keepers are kind
of coming off like their antagonists during the
series telling everybody the way their future is
supposed to unfold in arresting them or deleting
them if they don't agree with it but anytime
someone alters the timeline in a way that they
don't like or creates branch timelines alternate
realities that's when they arrest people i know
there's a lot of questions about why the avengers
didn't get arrested after avengers end game why
didn't they try to arrest thanos with the infinity
gauntlet if he was erasing half of all life that's
mostly because they didn't create branch timelines
and i know also sort of adding to the idea
that the timekeepers are kind of cynical kind
of antagonistic you know they allowed something
to happen it's because they wanted it to happen
implying that they wanted thanos to snap half of
the universe so of course the time keepers sound
kind of villainous but while loki is inside this
space for all intents and purposes the passage of
time for the main characters like thor the other
avengers in the main mcu timeline after avengers
end game is essentially meaningless yes time still
moves forward in the main timeline for all of them
but during the loki episodes what this version of
loki is essentially doing is jumping around from
one alternate reality branch timeline to another
in the past present and future of those alternate
realities and he can enter the main mcu timeline
at any point that the tva wants he can pop in
during the events of the older thor movies like
thor of the dark world he can show up on earth
earlier in the timeline like it seems like he's
in a version of pompeii here as the volcano is in
the middle of exploding but i know everyone's just
wondering what thor is doing in present day while
loki is off having these adventures with the tba
so i think this is easier to follow if you chart
the timeline based on the way that this version
of loki is experiencing the passage of time like
every day that he works for the tva here he still
gets one day older he ages one day his timeline
moves forward one day but for example in this
scene when he's having this conversation with moby
is just a couple moments after they arrest him
agreeing to his terms pretending like he's never
going to do anything bad ever again in his life of
course we believe him because he never tells lies
the year is still 2012 technically because this
is still a couple moments in this loki's timeline
after the end of the first avengers movie because
they just left from the year 2012. like loki has
only aged a day when this is happening thor also
aged a day but they just came from the year 2012
so for thor it's still 2012 when this is happening
so when this version of loki in the tv8 eventually
does meet the current version of thor in present
day of the mcu which obviously after end game is
2023 i'm believe thor love and dunder is supposed
to pick up in a linear fashion after the other
marvel movies so maybe it takes place during 2024
but it'll be this version of loki from the tva
who's a little bit older just dipping back into
the timeline at this point in the timeline for
the regular version of thor he's 10 years older
but this version of loki won't be 10 years older
he'll be meeting thor just a little while after
this like thor will have remembered watching loki
die like wait a minute i watched you die again
loki tends to do that quite a bit in the mcu
but this loki never experienced that so he won't
have the same relationship with thor that the
original loki had from infinity war but the whole
idea is though that over the course of the loki
series he's on a similar redemption arc and will
eventually become a more considerate character
more thoughtful about his actions slightly less
selfish and jealous just slightly so when he does
dip back into the timeline and cross over with
thor in present day the mcu he have a totally
different dynamic with thor kind of blow his mind
a little with the revelation of the time variance
authority existing a force of time cops across the
multiverse can't wait to see thor react to that
but as for this version of loki jumping around in
the timeline during these episodes encountering
versions of thor in other parts of the timeline
and the other characters from the thor movies like
heimdall odin his mother frigga the warriors 3 for
example you actually look at this db cooper scene
and all the trailers he's getting ready to jump
out the back of the plane you can hear him say
brother heimdall i hope you're ready just as the
bifrost catches them in midair so they can make
that big db cooper reference of him disappearing
without a trace quote unquote like this version of
loki in this timeline becomes the inspiration for
the db cooper legend it'll let you know that one
this is happening in the 1970s just charting
the timeline because that's when db cooper's
real-life heist happened that they're basing
this on two that thor and heimdall were very
much active and alive in asgard 40 50 years ago to
them 50 years is like 6 months for a regular human
so yes there is a version of thor in asgard when
this scene is happening who's monitoring loki's
actions right here with heimdall and heimdall is
operating the bifrost like he always did before
asgard was destroyed so yes this is a good example
of how thor is very much a part of the series but
the way tom hiddleston and kevin feige the
other producers talk about the loki series
is they wanted to separate the notion of the loki
character from what they call the thor odin son
saga like you have the infinity saga of movies
there's the thor odin son saga within the mcu
which is basically what they're calling the thor
movies like one of their proofs of concept they
talked about for the series that they started with
was what is loki's story when he's not with thor
all the time like what is loki's story if it's not
told from thor's perspective so the loki series is
sort of the answer to that like what's happening
when thor isn't around all the time stealing
loki's thunder to make all the thor puns so that's
why i'm not expecting a ton of chris hemsworth
showing up all over the place except when they're
referencing him in scenes like this like they'll
reference a lot of thor's stuff but thor himself
won't be flying around all over the place so
just do not be surprised if you don't see chris
hemsworth all over the episodes it's a lot like
the other avengers during Wandavision in falcon
and winter soldier same exact situation with the
way they handle the other avengers actors like in
this scene that we see in all the trailers loki is
in the avengers tower they're clearly parodying
this iconic avengers moment but they'll probably
have some clever way of working around the fact
that robert downey jr did not come back to film
new iron man scenes for the loki episodes so even
though they're referencing this iconic meeting
between those characters it'll look very different
during the actual episode the funny thing too is
tom hiddleston was talking about this classic
avengers end game scene that they sort of redid
for end game for this ending of the first avengers
movie tom hiddleston said that all this footage
here of them coming for loki and him asking
for the drink they actually re-shot all this
as if it were a totally new scene none of this is
reused footage all the actors got back into their
old costumes to re-film this stuff so talking a
little bit more about thor love and thunder and
connecting the loki episodes to that taikawat td
did a live stream earlier this year before they
started filming he was answering fans questions
like people asked will silver surfer be in thor
love and thunder in flat out no hesitation he's
like no no way mates not going to be doing any
of that no silver surfer in this movie but when
people asked him about tom hiddleston coming back
as a different version of loki so isn't to not
undermine his sacrifice in avengers infinity war
he got real quiet for a second paused and
then essentially said i can neither confirm
nor deny tom hiddleston will be in this movie
which obviously is exactly what you would say
if he's in the movie and is going to be super
twisty with the way they explained him showing up
he also said that it would be pretty weird of them
to make a thor movie without loki but i think sort
of complicating things is that when he was doing
this live stream he also couldn't spoil what they
were doing with the character in the loki series
so that's why you've seen so much secrecy around
what's happening with tom hiddleston during thor
love and thunder it's too bad tom holland and mark
ruffalo don't seem like they're in thor love
and thunder otherwise we'd know every single
thing about that movie but just a big reminder
that's all going to start next week loki episodes
will be posting on wednesday so that's what my
videos will be posting if you have any special
requests for bonus videos before then or any big
questions just leave them in the comments below
everyone seems to think that there's going to be a
big spider-man no way home trailer sometime in the
next week or so if that does wind up happening
they post it of course i'll do videos for it
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss anything i'll name a new
giveaway winner when i post my next marvel video
everyone click here for my new spiderman no way
home big announcement that they just made about
the future of the spiderman character is pretty
huge and click here for my new thor love and
thunder first look videos and teasers from the set
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!